We were on hiatus
during the Winter Olympics,
so here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! You guys!
The Olympics were crazy!
Okay, first of all, USA won its
first cross-country skiing gold,
and I was like, "What?!"
Then we won the gold
in women's hockey.
And everyone was like,
"Wh-a-at?!"
Then 17-year-old Red Gerard
overslept, lost his coat,
began in last place,
and ended up winning
the gold for snowboarding.
And everyone was like,
"Wh-a-a-a-at?!"
But he's a snowboarder,
so he was like, "Wh-u-u-ut?"
Then he said "holy [bleep]"
on live television,
and everyone was like,
"[Laughing] What?"
Then the North Korean
cheer squad had everyone like,
"What, what, what, what, what,
what, what, what, what,
what, what.
This is creeping me out."
Then figure skater Adam Rippon
refused to meet with Mike Pence
at the opening ceremonies,
tweeting, "I personally have
nothing to say to Mike Pence."
And I was like,
"What! Ah ha ha ha ha!
Neither do I!"
I like this guy.
And then I saw Adam in an
interview, and he said this.
-28 years old. Skating the best
you ever have in your life.
How do you explain that
to people?
-I can't explain witchcraft.
[ Laughter ]
What? What?
How do you explain witchcraft?
Is it this?
♪♪ Witch, witchcraft ♪♪
♪♪ Is this witchcraft,
witch, witch ♪♪
Scares me a little bit.
Then I saw curling,
and I was like,
"WHAT is this sport?
And why am I so drawn to it?"
Then I found out
a Russian curler was doping
and was like, "What? Why?
Did you get bored?"
Then American figure skater
Nathan Chen
hit six quadruple turns
in his routine,
and I was like, "What...
What...
Wh-a-a-a-at."
Then something great happened.
Novice skier Elizabeth Swaney
used a loophole
to sneak her way onto the
Hungarian Olympics team.
It was the most average
freestyle run of all time!
Look at this!
I was like,
"What are you doing?!"
She looks like
she fell asleep standing up
and then someone pushed her
down the halfpipe.
The woman did nothing
and then had the nerve
to be mad
that she got last place.
That's what happens
when you do the least.
You end up in last place.
Then Ivanka Trump flew out
for the closing ceremonies
and took a picture
holding a medal.
And I was like, "What?!
I didn't know nepotism
was an Olympic sport."
[ Cheers and applause ]
What.
Did she steal that medal
from that black lady?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Did that joke go too far?
'Cause you know who liked it?
These guys.
This has been "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]